okay I'm going to think about this time
before I actually say it good morning
John it's Thursday February 8th it is
it's very hard to make a video blog in
this house because there's no we're
private at all I have to talk very
quietly or else people will get me funny
they're looking at me funny mmm
kind of hiding in the corner in the
living room which is the room that I
sleep in in a sofa bed which is right
here to start out today's video I'm
going to give you a tour the place where
I am right now I am officially an
Inglewood Florida very very nice day
there's cars coming which is really
unusual for this street they would have
hit me at the exact same time he'll have
been painful yes now that's not gonna
mean cars for another two or three hours
and look around you'll see a normal
Florida fifties style Ranch House
neighborhood very nice place lots of
citrus flowers and cacti lots of
American flags this is a donkey with a
cactus in it that miraculously survived
Katherine throwing her calculus look at
it according to the sundial it is 11
o'clock this is remarkably accurate his
mom has non-traditional pink flamingos
behind me now is an orange tree over
there are two more orange trees and I
think a tangerine tree
and I'm going underneath some banana
trees now and then there's the canal
it's a very nice place
moving along gather experiences took me
to a very interesting event there were
about 400 old people watching about 30
old people playing banjos badly it turns
out the charlotte county has actually at
the highest age of any
in the country there are a lot of old
people here they played patriotic songs
they played take me out to the ballgame
they played more patriotic songs and
they played some military songs anyways
where's I've been thinking a lot about
babies lately you know the beginning of
life this made me think about something
entirely different
started to wonder or any of them going
to die while I was watching them so I've
done some Bo in calculations
I love Bo in calculations back of napkin
assuming that the average age of people
there was 70 and assuming that there
were around 400 people there and using
census data that says that the average
age of death of a 70 year old is 83 I
have calculated the probability that
someone would die at the event that I
just attended because the average age of
death of a 70 year old is 83 half of the
people at the event will be dead in 13
years
that is 113 thousand hours now because I
was at the event for three hours and
there were 400 old people there that
means 1200 total old people hours you
put that number over the total half-life
of an old person at the age of 70 and
then divide by 2 and get a 0.53 percent
chance that someone would die with an
eye shot of me this afternoon well
that's not a very big number it is
probably the biggest that number has
ever been in my life so now you know how
bored I am I accept your challenge and
will answer my survey the three minute
and 30 second time oh no is going to be
quite a barrier but I will do my best
and I very much enjoyed your children's
book I'm considering doing the
illustrations for it myself I'll see you
tomorrow